many of us grow up in families that very
carefully look after our needs but one
of the ambiguous achievements of having
been well parented is that a child comes
to assume that other people all other
people will always be alert to what they
want and feel that our genuine
requirements properly stated will always
meet with recognition and understanding
but inevitably as we grow into adults we
slam into something much more
frightening the rigid indifference of
the wider world a parking ticket won't
be waived because you're in a hurry and
need to pop into the corner shop to buy
a lemon the tax office won't say we
understand you've been a bit stress
recently so why don't you just return
your details when you can we know how it
is citing these kinds of needs makes
perfect sense in intimate relationships
but it's hopeless
as soon as we cross the boundary from
personal dealings to a zone that
dominates the modern world and can be
broadly summed up under the term
bureaucracy bureaucracy is an
ever-present ever fertile source of
agitation in our lives you're calling
the phone company to change your payment
plan they want to know your online
account number which you've forgotten
but you do have your password your
address your mother's maiden name and
information about your first pet a
collie kelpy cross called Pippy
unfortunately this won't suffice the
surface person doesn't doubt your
identity you both know it would be
bizarre for an impostor to attempt to
use your credit card to reduce a payment
on a phone connection but without the
particular account number you can't
proceed it's maddening not just because
it's time-consuming and inconvenient it
sets off fundamental alarm bells because
it's bringing one into a situation where
compassion understanding and human
connections have no power whatsoever to
solve problems where who you are in
other words a pretty decent honest and
well-meaning individual doesn't matter
in the least
the deeper stress is that the details of
your life count for nothing against the
purely formal requirements of an
administrative system the evolution of
bureaucracy is a major develop
and of the last 200 years in traditional
societies power used to be personal and
the relationships to people intimate the
clan chief knew and was related to all
the governed there was therefore always
a sense even if it might have been
frustrated in practice that one might be
able to sway the powerful to one's cause
the downside was that opportunities for
favoritism nepotism and bribery were
endless there was constant special
pleading and exceptions to the rules but
at least when you were up against it you
had a chance that a real human might
listen to your cries bureaucracy has on
the whole been an enormous achievement a
logical fair dispassionate machine for
dealing with large numbers of people
without fear or favor this was the point
beautifully articulated by the German
sociologist Max Weber at the end of the
19th century Weber argued that
government and industry became modern
when operating on a vast scale it
introduced universal fairness
instituting systematic processes and
standardizing rules so that there would
be correct ways of doing everything it
would no longer matter who your uncle
was or who your sister was married to
bureaucracy is a fine achievement of
maturity but it can appoints lead to
very painful conflicts with the specific
contours of individual cases this is the
nightmare of being trapped in an
unheated deaf cold cage but the apparent
unresponsiveness of bureaucracy is
rarely brought about by a deliberate
desire to ignore people's particular
situations it's an unfortunate
unavoidable byproduct of good and
reasonable intentions one specific needs
are being ignored in a broad interests
of fairness and keeping a big complex
undertaking going it's not as our panic
reaction sometimes suggests that
bureaucracy is out to get us or that
those who manage it are in themselves
soulless sadists the explanation is
strangely banal it's at the price of an
overall drive to efficiency is that some
small percentage of cases will become
horror
entangled and blocked but one can feel
like wholly obtuse reasons the calming
move is to see such unfortunate
incidents as inevitable rather than as
avoidable of France if we take it for
granted that the bureaucracies we deal
with banks utility companies Airlines
governments will be significantly
inefficient five percent of the time we
will understand that every so often our
dealings with them are sure to get
tangled the foundation of a newfound
calm is understanding an historical
perspective being calm doesn't mean that
one thinks a situation is agreeable or
interesting it just means that one knows
one would only add to the difficulties
by fuming and seething which stated in
the abstract can sound like a very small
development but when we recall the many
times of soul churning rage at the hands
of bureaucracies such calm reveals
itself as a huge and deeply benign piece
of wisdom to aim for
you